[Music]
all right Democrats quid quo pro well
now its primary narrative collapsing
they have shifted from extortion to
bribery from quid pro quo but once again
facts of getting in the way here to
shake it all out Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Lindsey Graham you
know I've been asking your colleagues
and we've been getting a lot of response
to the Federal Rules as it relates to
the admission of AD Vuitton's hearsay is
that going to be allowed in the Senate
they're all saying the same thing no
that would never be allowed in the
Senate who decides that would that be
the Senate making those rules or would
it be the Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court that would preside over this
madness it would be the Senate you would
have a resolution has to be passed by 51
votes setting the terms and conditions
of the trial in the Senate that has to
be done by Senate resolution what I will
insist upon to get my vote is that the
Federal Rules of Evidence apply to the
case presented in the house so president
Trump's defense team could object to
hearsay and I think about 95% of the
testimony Falls the other thing I wanted
to end the trial resolution is the
ability to confront one's accuser
because if you want to call the
whistleblower in the Senate I think you
have a right to do that because that's
the person who started all this and the
the right to confront your accusers
basic due process well that's the sixth
amendment to the US Constitution you're
an attorney I would think that that's
basic and fundamental I I couldn't
imagine a Chief Justice that would
preside over this and allow hearsay
evidence that is not admissible in terms
of federal law and I can't believe that
the Chief Justice of Supreme Court would
not go along with the very clear
unambiguous language of the Constitution
I wouldn't believe that would happen sir
well you got to set the rules for the
trial we had a hundred and nothing
resolution regarding the Clinton
proceedings I don't think Democrats are
going to work with Mitch McConnell I
hope I'm wrong but is it too much to ask
that President Trump be given the same
rights as every other American in a
parking ticket case that you can't get a
parking ticket based on hearsay and
you're able to confront the person
accuse
you of illegal parking those basic
things have to be in the trial
resolution I believe and I hope we can
get 51 votes for the idea I just
expressed okay so you see what's
happening over there the tooth I can't
get over the arguments that they're
trying to make about the president when
we read the transcript everybody we're
basically interviewing people to talk
about the transcript that we all get to
read ourselves and what they think of a
transcript doesn't matter what they
think in the end about the transcript
because we see the transcript we also
know that that that Ukraine did nothing
and they got the money they did nothing
we also know that the president said of
Ukraine sit and did five times no
pressure so but we do have the issue of
the Biden's I'm having a hard time with
that hypocrisy here how do you do say no
the nobody of credibility has ever said
there's anything wrong here yeah
nobody's looked well buddies looked
nobody's looked I'm looking and what I
see is really bad the very thing they're
getting outraged about Joe Biden's
admitting billion dollars fire the
prosecutor you don't get the billion if
you don't his son gets millions and he
actually said nope no experience
whatsoever none zero
well here here's the argument that Joe
Biden was asking the prosecutor to be
fired because who his corrupt but here's
the question I don't believe it well but
here's the question all these phone
calls that took place between Biden and
President poroshenko the then president
the Ukraine most of them occurred after
the raid on the gas company by the
prosecution flowed out so I want
everyone to hear you this is a phone
calls that took place between the former
president of Ukraine and Joe Biden right
around the time this is happening wait a
minute there are transcripts of those
calls well here's what somebody needs to
ask okay Joe Biden had the Ukraine
portfolio about every month he would
call the Ukraine but after the raid on
the gas company where hunter Biden was a
board member they raided the president
of the gas company's home after that you
see about three to four phone calls and
four
five days between Joe Biden and the
president the Ukraine then you see the
case dropped you also see hunter Biden's
business partners contacting the State
Department complaining about the raid on
the the gas company and saying it would
you know this could affect hunter Biden
I want somebody to look into that I want
the transcripts released
I want the Putin Obama transcripts
released after had more flexibility
I want the Obama Iranian mullahs
transcripts released though a 50 billion
I gotta ask you what an off question
here on December 11th Michael Horowitz
that means we're gonna get it hopefully
the week before so we can absorb it and
not on a Friday know Friday dumb yeah I
hope so yeah I think so I think you're
going to be just stay tuned December the
11th be here before you know it and
it'll be out before the hearing
is this another BS it's coming or is
this the real deal you can put this one
in the bank all right senator thank you
for all you're doing we appreciate it